[Music]
so i'm really honored to have you on the
show today i'm
actually extremely excited to talk to
someone in such film royalty like
yourself
uh so what's really cool about this
movie for you in maneri
you're this heavy favorite now to be
nominated for an oscar and not only
favorite to be nominated
but to actually win for best supporting
actress did you ever
dream about possibly getting an oscar
one day and getting oh no
no no this is i even never even dreamt
about
me being on nominated or
in the states oh but so
i i really don't know how to react and
to me it's not real to me at all still
and so i don't know how to have a very
nice element way to speak about
how grateful i am or something like that
so
thank you so excuse me when i get rude
so please it's just my lack of english
not
my feeling my feeling is grateful and
it's just
unreal yeah no and it's awesome because
you're
just a trailblazer for just america
because you're the first
korean actor to be even nominated for a
sag award which is just
awesome um so speaking of this role you
play the grandma and minari
and i was wondering there's such a range
of emotions
in this role um what was your kind of
your process like as an actress because
you do it so well
how do you kind of prepare
it's all director's help and then my
code actually they're leading acting
actresses they they
you know we all become a family and then
we
just what read the line the line says
it says everything so we just didn't
have
it's not we didn't have a good time but
anyway we were just
trying to make it that happen in
that set so that's what happened to me
yeah so speaking of like the caster with
was it
challenging playing that your main scene
partner is a kid across from you was
that like an interesting experience and
such a huge age gap oh
no it was i used to work with all that
nowadays in korea of course my age is
very very now i became a legend just
because
i mean it's a long time it's not
pleasant feeling
so well i have many experience
playing with the younger generation so
it wasn't
very difficult or new
to me it's sure no and that definitely
shows and
it's amazing that you've been doing this
acting thing for over
55 years and uh
what is interesting to me is that this
is actually your first american film
debut
is there any kind of comparisons you can
make to maybe some surprises you found
doing an american film that was
different than doing a film in korea
oh yes there's a lot of difference
because
because in korea most of people knows me
especially in my
industry that they all know me so
they know what they're not supposed to
do
to me or you know try to please me or
something but
in tulsa nobody knows me so
my first job was i'm supposed to be the
um what the first
in korea like in my
senior they always respect senior so
they ask me should i just you know call
you this
time or something like that but there's
no
no asking just so they ordered me just
to get in
okay on the set and nine a.m by nine am
and then i will be the first person to
filming that day usually usually in
korea i avoid that kind of situation
i try not to go in first day because the
first day is not going to be right
it's going to be chaos but i was the
first person to go that set so that was
one what can i do so that five days in a
row
five nobody calls me five five days
in a row in korea we do if i
work one day and then i would have a
rest
next day and you know like this they
were just
concerned about my health and my
condition nobody concerned about my
health and condition
so wow this is tulsa or hollywood wow
i'm not going to come
coming here again
[Laughter]
that was my experience wow um
yeah that's that's really interesting
and it's interesting because you have
like
this whole life story behind you and you
have experience
with immigrating to the united states
did you take
any of that experience into the role of
this film
i'm sure it affected me because i've
been lived
here about eight or nine years because
the reason i'm trying to just
make it shorter time to stay because my
english
because it was back in 74 74 till
uh 82 i lived in the state as a student
wife's visa and i was just housewife so
i just
speak leaving english and hear me giving
the interview with
you special people like you so it's
i don't know how to say you and this is
a terrible time actually
i don't know how to describe and this my
english is was
already gone long time ago so right and
it's kind of a miracle just speaking in
english now
no it's it sounds like you've been
speaking your whole life english it
sounds great
and you're you're a pro this is amazing
if i give you a word for that too i
would um thank you very much
this is uh it's interesting though
because i wonder
from someone in your perspective do you
in your life at any point watch a lot of
american films or is there any
american actors or actresses you like
admire
oh yes yes we've been all over the world
they've been watching american
film of course well yes every time but
me
just every time when they first come out
wow that's my hobby oh he's going to
make it someday or what's his name okay
there's nobody
no nobody asked me but that's my hobby
and then always i'm right so then i'm so
proud of myself
nobody asked me i'm not the critic
i love that um so because you've been
like
doing this for such a long time do you
still
love acting as much as you did when you
began
when when i began i don't i didn't know
i didn't realize what i'm doing actually
when you are young you don't know
anything but now
after 60 i am enjoying it after 60 i'm
enjoying
that's actually really interesting and
it's interesting when you
do these performances on set and then
they come out do you actually
watch your own performance after you
kind of just let it be
i hate to watch myself on the screen
that's just a
torturing moment to me so i just
avoid not to watch it avoid avoid
not watch it but sometimes you know
premiere you got to go see
yourself in big screening with the
audience or
people that is just oh
i just try not to go but sometimes i
the reason i hate to go watch myself is
because i
always think why would i do that like
that
i could have been better than that that
just so i cannot enjoy the movie at all
so maybe a couple years later
or all by myself i watch it over again
then i could enjoy it
uh no that's honest answer i love that
and uh
it's interesting cause you're just
talking about too like how you approach
just
uh the craft of acting and if you watch
yourself or not but i feel like because
this movie's getting so much press and
it's in the whole award circuit people
also with all your nominations are going
to look up to you in america now as an
actress
and is there any advice you would give i
don't like if you had to give your best
advice for an upcoming actress what
would you say
i don't have that kind of position i
don't think i'm
i'm not the person who gives advice i
need
advice from somebody i need a lot of
help from my friends
no not me i cannot okay how about this
if you were to go back in time and talk
to your younger self
what would you tell her if you were to
go back and talk to
young self what would you say
oh okay what would i say
what no i'm not i just
didn't regret i i don't regret the time
i was
when i was young i was just so i'm i'm
sure i was
just ignoring though i'm sure but that
was the time i needed that
that i think when i was young so no it's
okay life is just
once you only live once so you you do
whatever it wants to do
that's my theory theory am i saying
right
yeah yeah no that's that's great wisdom
and um
so because you're just this talented
person and people can be so interested
in the states
about you now i'm sure people wondering
what are other
things you love to do or passions you
have besides acting
[Music]
acting is not fun yes
that's enough and then um when i'm not
working like just to
i love to read the novel but nowadays i
realized
my my eyes get hurt after one hour so oh
i should study when i was younger
because when you get old you cannot
study or
you know so you should listen to your
mother that's the lesson i'm
i got nowadays and
well i love to see my friend
talking with them just chatting is my
hobby
that's that's great and i guess that's
the point of life right just chat with
friends
hanging out um so
now before i let you go what will you
take away most from your experience
working on this film
maneri or something even the film maybe
touched you about
this minari yeah
well i really like aiza
very much i even respected him because
he's
much younger than me he's not he's my
second son's age but he was so mature
while we were filming he was just very
patient with the young actors and
patient with
all that cool so i wasn't like i am not
like
that person i'm very temperamental i get
very
exploded when i get upset but so
i was i ended him and
but i tried to learn but no
that's not my character i think so
[Laughter]
i'll just saying isaac just watching him
mom
he's very different than with me that's
why he became a director
yeah no that's that's great and you know
what i can tell i'm just talking to you
for this
short time is that you have great
character and you seem so friendly and
it's awesome that you just realize that
interview because you're so good on
screen i think
you're just going to be a new hero now
to people in america
who are into acting i think i know so
i know so and uh everyone
yes you you have to see this movie it's
in theaters now
it is minari and it will be available on
demand february 26th
as well i can't wait to watch you get
your oscar
very soon and thank you so much
for joining me today and i hope to talk
to you in the future oh
thank you to having me thank you
have a good one